Tom sprintz Tom leaps Tom hangs on for
dear life it's time to set your brain
for cruise control
right out of the gate we have to talk
about Tom's tendency to run because this
particular trademark has reached levels
of absurdity at this point
don't run you don't have to chase me you
don't have to run dating all the way
back to 1981's Taps Thomas found a way
to show off his incredible knack for
sprinting in all but a handful of films
the legal drama The Firm gave him
several opportunities to dash around in
a suit and Cameron Crowe even figured
out a way to slip a sequence of Tom's
running technique into two non-action
films the opening of 2001's mind-bending
drama Vanilla Sky and the tail end of
the 1996 romantic comedy drama Jerry
Maguire those were warm-ups nowadays
when Tom runs he runs you need only pop
in any of the mission impossible
features to catch a glimpse of his fancy
footwork in fact JJ Abrams devotes
nearly an entire minute of the climax of
Mission Impossible 3 to Tom literally
sprinting in pursuit of the film's key
villain the latest trailer for Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 1 teases
viewer with a brief shot of the man the
myth the legend running through a
mysterious Locale immediately following
his name credit so yeah at this point it
seems Tom is in on the joke
Tom's wild stunts weren't always a
staple in his films there are no
death-defying leaps off of high-rises in
Rainman or vertigo-inducing jet battles
in eyes wide shut but the actor still
managed to show off his need for
adrenaline fueled Antics early in his
career case in point in The Outsiders
Tom's character does a backflip for no
apparent reason after running out of a
house according to actor Rob Lowe in an
interview with Entertainment Tonight
director Francis Ford Coppola asked the
cast to learn how to do a backflip and
Tom was the only one capable of pulling
off the difficult feat check this out
buddy
the actor also insisted on driving a
real NASCAR race car in Days of Thunder
and according to a profile in Rolling
Stone rode the fastest horse on set
during the climactic land race in Far
and Away it's small potatoes compared to
the stunts he achieves in the mummy and
the mission impossible films and his
other action-based roles but worth
noting so why does he do it during an
appearance on The Graham Norton Show Tom
admitted it all comes down to the
storytelling saying I feel that you're
bringing everything you know physically
and emotionally to a character in a
story I've trained for 30 years doing
stunts and it allows us to put cameras
in places where you are normally not
able to
not only is Tom Cruise a thrilled junkie
but he also loves himself a slick
motorcycle a fact made abundantly clear
when the actor memorably rode a Kawasaki
gpz-900r along an Airport runway in
1986's Top Gun over 35 years later Tom
once again hopped aboard a Kawasaki the
ninja H2 to be exact aka the fastest
motorcycle in the world for the
enormously successful sequel top gun
Maverick in the interim Tom has thrilled
audiences with his astonishing
motorcycle skills in John Woo's Mission
Impossible 2 Joseph Kaczynski sublivion
and Mission Impossible Fallout Tom's
Love for motorcycles extends off screen
as well apparently after wrapping a
project the actor will take home or
purchase the motorcycle used in the film
and add it to his vast collection
according to Notorious Tom has in his
possession the BMW
S1000RR used in Mission Impossible Rogue
Nation the triumph am Thruxton used in
Edge of Tomorrow and yes even that
Kawasaki from Top Gun among others and
if motorcycles don't exist in the
context of the movie Tom will usually
hop on a horse instead but we say that
counts what is a horse if not a
motorcycle with legs
while many of Tom's movies feature the
box office star working alongside a
group of notable co-stars there always
seems to be a moment where his character
must cut the ripcord and go solo to save
the day we see this often in the mission
impossible franchise in which Tom's IMF
agent Ethan Hunt leaves his teammates in
the dust to go one-on-one with the
film's principal bad guy we didn't have
this conversation
I disappeared in London you don't know
where I am
if I'm dead or alive but this trait also
extends to some of the actor's more
dramatic Ventures notably in A Few Good
Men Tom's cocky lawyer ignores the
advice of his team and takes on Jack
Nicholson's sharp tongued Colonel Nathan
Jessup all on his own likewise in 2008's
Valkyrie based on real events Tom's
one-armed one-eyed Colonel plots with an
assortment of German officers to
assassinate Adolf Hitler and ends up
planting the bomb himself other Cruise
Vehicles such as Minority Report Jack
Reacher born on the 4th of July and the
firm positioned Tom against an evil or
corrupt establishment that he must
battle on his own I am not a hero I'm a
Drifter with nothing to lose
you can't really discuss Tom Cruise
without acknowledging his vast
collection of Shades whether he's mixing
drinks on the beach driving Dustin
Hoffman cross country or simply jumping
out of explosions Tom Cruise has an eye
for a classy pair of eyewear in Risky
Business and Top Gun Tom slid on
Ray-Bans and helped popularize the brand
in the 1980s according to Mental Floss
there's one thing I've learned in all my
years
sometimes you gotta say what the [ __ ]
and in Top Gun Maverick the shades were
so important that his Ray-Bans were
custom made to fit his face in other
words it aimed a Tom Cruise film unless
it features Tom Cruise in sunglasses
aside from a few exceptions Tom is
typically the de facto star of the films
he appears in so yeah it makes sense
that his character always ends up saving
the day from the forces of evil of
course that's outside of films where he
is the force of evil like Interview with
the Vampire and collateral and even in
collateral his cold-hearted assassin
influences Jaime Fox's World weary cab
driver enough to force a positive change
in the young man's life which can
technically be seen as a win for Tom
without Vincent it's doubtful Max ever
finds the confidence needed to dump his
crappy job and move on with his life
otherwise Tom is typically the man of
the hour by the final reel of any film
whether it's stopping dastardly
terrorists or corrupt operatives from
destroying the world saving Iceman and
rooster in the Top Gun films or taking
down an alien tripod to save his
daughter in War of the Worlds you can
pretty much count on Tom Cruise to get
the job done
foreign
no matter the circumstances Tom Cruise
characters always get the girl in Risky
Business he ends up with Lana the
sensitive sex worker Top Gun sees our
beleaguered hero ride off with Kelly
McGillis and Minority Report rewards his
efforts by fixing him up with his
estranged wife and A Few Good Men it's
strongly hinted that to me more has eyes
for Tom while Cameron Diaz locks lips
with our main man in night and day those
are just a few examples but it's clear
Tom's characters can get any woman they
want now whether they're attracted to
the killer good looks impeccable fashion
sense or heart swelling one-liners is a
topic worth discussing
Tom Cruise may be the king of cool but
even the most even-keeled action heroes
lose their patience every now and then
and God forbid you get in his way when
it happens
as it turns out an explosive temper is
practically a trademark of his
characters it's little wonder that Ben
Stiller cast him as the foul-mouthed
less Grossman in the 2008 comedy Tropic
Thunder hidden under layers of
Prosthetics Tom shouts curses and dances
away with the film revealing a darker
side that somehow fits snugly amidst the
comic antics of the movie more
dramatically in A Few Good Men Tom rages
against a meme or after she makes an
error and even does the toss everything
off the desk bit for good measure in
Mission Impossible he justifiably loses
his cool after his entire team is killed
during a mission gone wrong he even gets
a little grumpy at his kids in War of
the Worlds I'm not hungry either
you're not hungry either
okay
okay it's fun
these are but a few examples of Tom's
ability to blow a gasket but make no
mistake Tom has many captivating
Tantrums throughout his filmography
save for his overweight character Les
Grossman Tom typically carries an
incredible physique that he's clearly
not afraid to show off at every possible
opportunity
foreign
Jack Reacher for example Tom sheds his
shirt and attempts to carry a serious
conversation with Rosamund Pikes Helen
Roden likewise in the action comedy
night and day Tom Wows Cameron Diaz
during a foray on a tropical island in
Mission Impossible Rogue Nation he sheds
his top for an exciting fight sequence
during which he crunches up a pole to
escape and who could forget the infamous
volleyball scene in Top Gun hey if
you've got it flaunt it I'm sorry could
you please put a shirt on
this is my shirt
we've already discussed Tom's obsession
with motorcycles but that's only part of
the story nearly every Tom Cruise movie
features the actor going really fast
either by running driving flying boating
or vampiric trickery
Top Gun is the obvious choice here but
also consider Ron Howard's dramatic epic
Far and Away in which Tom hops on a
horse and outruns everyone to claim his
piece of Oklahoma property or how about
Minority Report where he leaps around on
cars on a futuristic highway he rides a
speeding car off a bridge in Vanilla Sky
and of course much of Days of Thunder
takes place on a race track so yeah Tom
Cruise means it when he says I feel the
need
grenade for a speed
and while almost all his movies feature
Tom's characters going fast it's not
uncommon for the actor himself to be
hitting the same speeds in fact Newsweek
notes that in Top Gun Maverick the actor
took to the skies in an actual fighter
jet while Mission Impossible Fallout
gave him a chance to fly a helicopter
through snow-covered mountains Smith's
sonian magazine details how American
made allowed the actor to put his
pilot's license to use and perform
intense flying sequences in a six-seater
piper Aerostar 600 and a Cessna 414
it's a weird trademark but at some point
in many of Tom's films the actor is
forced to hang on to something for dear
life mission impossible Rogue Nation
might take the cake for literal
representation of it but there are so
many instances of the Superstar clinging
to the side of something or other in a
desperate attempt to keep himself from
falling in night and day the action
Maestro hangs onto Cameron Diaz's car
while battling bad guys in War of the
Worlds he hangs onto a group of
strangers to avoid being sucked into an
alien ship and he spends most of Rock of
Ages barely clinging to his own sanity
which that counts right
[Music]
foreign
most famously Tom hung off the side of
the massive Burj Khalifa building four
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol even
Edge of Tomorrow featured the actor
clinging to an object a machine gun
attached to a military aircraft during
the action-packed climax at the end of
the day we'll continue to enjoy his many
death-defying Feats for as long as he's
willing to perform them
foreign